but why can't we both go out to work and
because if we both because we have roles
so it's either i go out and do it or you
go out and do it because over time we
figured out that's the best way to be
why can't we just both do it no you
don't understand men like men have like
this thing in them when they see their
woman doing certain things it's like
just like women have it in men like when
they see men doing certain things like
you know that sometimes women see a man
like putting together a shelf and
they're like
or whatever it is whatever it is that
you see a man doing and you're like um
yeah that's manly like men have the same
thing so when a man sees a woman do
certain things that are in their
feminine like cooking like i love
watching a woman cook love it i'm like
and that's for me yeah that's what i'm
like why'd you not hate it so it's like
i'm like i love what you cook for me and
my belly's full like
the world is yours you know like yeah
it's the oyster like right you know what
that is right yeah
right that's what we do
that's how we are